we are joined by Candace Owens the host
of canvas and we're always happy to have
her Candace thanks so much for coming on
it does seem like Anna coutini was one
of these ideas you know that some
political thoughts were thought up a
long time ago but I I I I I don't think
it could be clear that's what we're
watching
absolutely and I will say this about
this cultural demise that we're facing I
know people are understandably outraged
and people are understandably anger but
I also want to comment on just the
overwhelming Despair and sadness that
all of this is making me feel and I know
that so many people at home are feeling
the exact same way not just about
America's present feeling Bleak about
the future dystopian nightmare that
we're currently existing and but also
Looking Backward you know one of the
things that I think a lot of us are
feeling is disillusionment uh with with
what American Justice is even about
we've spent the better half of the last
century entering in other countries
saying that we have a right to be here
because we're spreading quote-unquote
democracy we've completely lost the
moral High Ground I'm not sure if we
ever really had it we have a right to be
in Iraq Iran Afghanistan because we have
better our principles are better because
these people are criminals because these
people are terrorists because these
people have the wrong ideas now all of a
sudden our government is turning that
same ideology against the American
people right now we have the wrong ideas
now we are the domestic terrorists now
we are the people that need to
understand that criminality is allowed
to flock Ai and so it's incredibly
despairing and and I just want to speak
on that first and foremost you know to
look and say that overseas we used to
talk about how these terrorists were
locking up their political dissidents
now we're doing exactly the same thing
we're locking up grandmas in the Capitol
Building we're putting people in prison
uh for years for the offense of
trespassing we are now locking up a
political Contender you're saying Donald
Trump must be arraigned we can't tell
you why we're going to issue a gag order
if any of this took place overseas could
you imagine what the response would be
would be demanding boots on the ground
tomorrow to spread democracy but here
they completely Overlook it
calling attacks on the existing system
hate speech which is a completely fake
and made up category If you eliminate
Free Speech you don't have democracy
democracy requires Free Speech or it
doesn't exist and we would know that if
it were happening in a foreign country
you're so right Kenneth appreciate your
coming on tonight thank you subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube channel to catch
our nightly opens stories that are
changing the world and changing your
life from Tucker Carlson tonight